one player is trapped in a vita room
with a ticking time bomb
they must diffuse the other player are
an expert must give the instructions to
defuse the bomb may deciphering the
information founded about the usual menu
but there is a batch the expert can see
the book everyone loves to talk it out
vas
uh-huh
cry okay Minato I'm in a dark room it's
9:45 oh god what's going out God dark
room where we play life is strange again
I got a bomb right in front of me all
right let's go um it's it's got a timer
we have five minutes before the bomb is
gonna explode you guys sounds good I
mean bad no it's just not sound good and
battery why are you laughing
it's not a joke is not a joke okay I'm
serious let's go we don't have time for
this
okay there's there's six slots huh so
goddamn two of them are empty
oh there's one that looks like alien
illuminati codes on it [ __ ] ileal
there's a countdown timer okay
oh yeah there's there's five cables oh
geez okay how about go go to the alien
illuminati kill Illuminati coats it's
like four of them right yes there's four
there's four why do I do time is running
out explain the Illuminati comes to me
which what do they look like okay
there's one sailor moon moon with a dot
in it a backwards moon a sailor moon
moon with a dot in it it's backwards so
it's like it's like a seed yes the other
way yes okay I'm dotting it okay I see
that already got it take out I'm sorry
hurry ugh I don't want to die I want to
die either let's go alright what's the
next you are in a safe spot
okay you're right however heart attacks
happen to any point what let's go okay
there's a triangle okay with on the
floor and a tea inside of it and then
there's a circle with a little penis
going down a circle with a penis going
are you is this actually a bomb what the
[ __ ] you there's just a bomb if you
serious we have three minutes okay all
right okay what do I do so press the the
backwards C with a dot on it are you
sure maybe possibly okay alright when I
got him
I'm sorry man I don't okay okay okay I'm
clicking it okay I get it okay I'm
taking it okay
no no red light red light rather like ah
I'll try Oh God press the triangle
triangle yes
try there red light red light [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's the battery there's a battery on
top of it this is battery
okay there's a should I just pull out
the battery pull it yank it out I can't
oh [ __ ] it's tight back two minutes two
minutes a big are gonna die crisis
political your lovely symbols again from
the order of top left to the bottom
right two minutes okay see backwards
with a dot inside of it the right of it
it's a triangle with a teen side of it
with no floor okay the other one has a
triangle upside down with an it looks
like an e underneath it tilted at 90
degrees okay then no and then a circle
with little line going down from it door
yeah we're with the store Willis no I
press press the circle with a line going
down it uh it lit up green okay let up
green now what do I do next on go with
it see in it a little green a little
break
hey hey hey we did it I did it
Oh God Oh God well one minute wait a
minute wait a minute
okay okay go next one that is it okay
come on boom I'm suffering to two red
cables to one black one yellow one white
key [ __ ] um I don't want to die
everybody I'm trying man I'm trying to
rent black yellow why those tables
there's only top to bottom
cry 20 seconds sorry this two cables no
there's five to red one black one yellow
one white cotton ball
you can't make rap you said cut them off
oh god oh god
come on gonna hunt you I was so
stressful you know what what what what
was your [ __ ] problem let that was
actually a trust test the hell are you
on the back there that was a fake bomb
no yeah that actually was no yes no
[ __ ] alliance [ __ ] with your fun wait
a minute yeah I'm still alive see you're
right you're welcome ah huh what a
relief
what a relief I thought I was a goner
yeah I know it [ __ ] happens right um
well yep it's it's funny how you say
that because cry yes there's still
another bump that one's a real bomb
finish they think they skipped my trap
for now you are safe but the next video
never be a bigger challenge and a much
bigger bomb is your charge this video
leave a like subscribe and the see you
next video bro fished their ass yeah I'm
done haha oh that was awesome
[ __ ] yeah okay are you ready for the
final penis I don't think you are
yep it's pretty much it now the flowers
will grow